how many intelligent aliens
civilizations do you think are out there
and uh is their intelligence
different or similar to ours
yeah I've been preoccupied with this
question quite a bit recently uh
basically from for me Paradox and just
thinking through and and the reason
actually that I am very interested in uh
the origin of life is fundamentally
trying to understand how common it is
that there are technological societies
out there uh
um in space and the more I study it the
more I think that um
uh there should be quite a few quite a
lot why haven't we heard from them
because I I agree with you it feels like
I just don't see
why what we did here on Earth is so
difficult to do yeah and especially when
you get into the details of it I used to
think origin of life was very
um
it was this magical rare event but then
you read books like for example McLean
um uh the vital question a life
ascending Etc and he really gets in and
he really makes you believe that this is
not that rare basic chemistry you have
an active Earth and you have your
alkaline Vents and you have lots of
alkaline Waters mixing with the devotion
and you have your proton gradients and
you have the little porous pockets of
these alkaline vents that concentrate
chemistry and
um basically as he steps through all of
these little pieces you start to
understand that actually this is not
that crazy you could see this happen on
other systems
um and he really takes you from just a
geology to primitive life and he makes
it feel like it's actually pretty
plausible and also like the origin of
life
um
didn't uh was actually fairly fast after
formation of Earth
um if I remember correctly just a few
hundred million years or something like
that after basically when it was
possible life actually arose and so that
makes me feel like that is not the
constraint that is not the limiting
variable and that life should actually
be fairly common
um and then it you know where the
drop-offs are is very
um is very interesting to think about I
currently think that there's no major
drop-offs basically and so there should
be quite a lot of life and basically
what it where that brings me to then is
the only way to reconcile the fact that
we haven't found anyone and so on is
that
um we just can't we can't see them we
can't observe them just a quick brief
comment Nick Lane and a lot of
biologists I talked to they really seem
to think that the jump from bacteria to
more complex organisms is the hardest
jump the eukaryotic like yeah which I
don't I get it they're much more
knowledgeable uh than me about like the
intricacies of biology but that seems
like crazy because how much how many
single cell organisms are there like and
how much time you have surely it's not
that difficult like in a billion years
is not even that long
of a time really just all these bacteria
under constrained resources battling it
out I'm sure they can invent more
complex again I don't understand it's
like how to move from a hello world
program to like like invent a function
or something like that I don't yeah I
I so I don't yeah so I'm with you I just
feel like I don't see any if the origin
of life that would be my intuition
that's the hardest thing but if that's
not the hardest thing because it happens
so quickly then it's got to be
everywhere and yeah maybe we're just too
dumb to see it well it's just we don't
have really good mechanisms for seeing
this life I mean uh by what
how um so I'm not an expert just to
preface this but just at it it was I
want to meet an expert on alien
intelligence and how to communicate I'm
very suspicious of our ability to to
find these intelligences out there and
to find these Earths like radio waves
for example are are terrible uh their
power drops off as basically one over R
square uh so I remember reading that our
current radio waves would not be uh the
ones that we we are broadcasting would
not be uh measurable by our devices
today only like was it like one tenth of
a light year away like not even a
basically tiny distance because you
really need like a targeted transmission
of massive power directed somewhere for
this to be picked up on long distances
and so I just think that our ability to
measure is um is not amazing I think
there's probably other civilizations out
there and then the big question is why
don't they build binomial probes and why
don't they Interstellar travel across
the entire galaxy and my current answer
is it's probably Interstellar travel is
like really hard uh you have the
interstellar medium if you want to move
at closer speed of light you're going to
be encountering bullets along the way
because even like tiny hydrogen atoms
and little particles of dust are
basically have in like massive kinetic
energy at those speeds and so basically
you need some kind of shielding you need
you have all the cosmic radiation uh
it's just like brutal out there it's
really hard and so my thinking is maybe
Interstellar travel is just extremely
hard
and you have billions of years to build
hard
it feels like uh it feels like we're not
a billion years away from doing that it
just might be that it's very you have to
go very slowly potentially as an example
through space
um right as opposed to close the speed
of light so I'm suspicious basically of
our ability to measure life and I'm
suspicious of the ability to um just
permeate all of space in the Galaxy or
across galaxies and that's the only way
that I can I can currently see a way
around it yeah it's kind of mind-blowing
to think that there's
trillions of intelligent alien
civilizations out there kind of slowly
traveling through space
to meet each other and some of them meet
some of them go to war some of them
collaborate and they're all just uh
independent they are all just like
little pockets I don't know well
statistically if there's like
if it's there's trillions of them surely
some of them some of the pockets are
close enough to get some of them happen
to me close yeah in the close enough to
see each other and then once you see
once you see something that is
definitely complex life like if we see
something yeah we're probably going to
be severe like intensely aggressively
motivated to figure out what the hell
that is and try to meet them what would
be your first instinct to try to like at
a generational level meet them or defend
against them or what would be your uh
Instinct as a president of the United
States
and the scientists
I don't know which hat you prefer in
this question
yeah I think the the question it's
really hard
um
I will say like for example for us
um we have lots of primitive life forms
on Earth
um next to us we have all kinds of ants
and everything else and we share space
with them and we are hesitant to impact
on them and to we are and we're trying
to protect them by default because they
are amazing interesting dynamical
systems that took a long time to evolve
and they are interesting and special and
I don't know that you want to
um destroy that by default and so I like
complex dynamical systems that took a
lot of time to evolve I think
I'd like to I like to preserve it if I
can afford to and I'd like to think that
the same would be true about uh the
galactic resources and that uh they
would think that we're kind of
incredible interesting story that took
time it took a few billion years to
unravel and you don't want to just
destroy it I could see two aliens
talking about Earth right now and saying
uh I'm I'm a big fan of complex
dynamical systems so I think it was a
value to preserve these and who
basically are a video game they watch or
show a TV show that they watch
yeah I think uh you would need like a
very good reason I think to
to destroy it uh like why don't we
destroy these ant farms and so on it's
because we're not actually like really
in direct competition with them right
now uh we do it accidentally and so on
but
um
there's plenty of resources and so why
would you destroy something that is so
interesting and precious well from a
scientific perspective you might probe
it yeah you might interact with it like
you might want to learn something from
it right so I wonder there's could be
certain physical phenomena that we think
is a physical phenomena but it's
actually interacting with us to like
poke the finger and see what happens I
think it should be very interesting to
scientists other alien scientists what
happened here
um and you know it's a what we're seeing
today is a snapshot basically it's a
it's a result of a huge amount of
computation
uh of over like billion years or
something like that so it could have
been initiated by aliens this could be a
computer running a program like when
okay if you had the power to do this
when you okay for sure at least I would
I would pick a Earth-like planet that
has the conditions based my
understanding of the chemistry
prerequisites for life
and I would see it with life and run it
right like yeah wouldn't you 100 do that
and observe it and then protect
I mean that that's not just a hell of a
good TV show it's it's a good scientific
experiment yeah and
that it means it's physical simulation
right maybe maybe the evolution is the
most like actually running it
uh is the most efficient way to uh
understand computation or to compute
stuff or to understand life or you know
what life looks like and uh what
branches it can take but it does make me
kind of feel weird that we're part of a
science experiment but maybe it's
everything's a science experiments how
to does that change anything for us if
we're a science experiment
um I don't know two descendants of Apes
talking about being inside of a science
experience I'm suspicious of this idea
of like a deliberate Pence Premiere as
you described it sort of and I don't see
a divine intervention in some way in the
in the historical record right now I do
feel like
um the story in these in these books
like Nick Lane's books and so on sort of
makes sense uh and it makes sense how
life arose on Earth uniquely and uh yeah
I don't need a I need I don't need to
reach for more exotic explanations right
now sure but NPCs inside a video game
don't don't don't observe any divine
intervention either we might just be all
NPCs running a kind of code maybe
eventually they will currently NPCs are
really dumb but once they're running
gpts maybe they will be like hey this is
really suspicious what the hell